um what obviously besides the music
um are you dipping your foot into any
other sort of entrepreneurial [ __ ]
opening to some businesses or real
estate or anything like that
yeah I always got my hands in some but I
won't be going to be like the face of it
I don't be wanting to be the one to take
credit for it right so I just stay
behind and closed doors right silent
investor yeah for sure that's smart like
that's why I can't nobody figure me out
without would you ever Act
yeah for sure have you have you thought
about doing that yeah this one that's
what I'm finna do really
when I get done with this with this
little rap [ __ ] I mean what does that
mean
like when you're done with the when like
you're gonna retire eventually
yeah was that the goal because you know
some guys are rapping I don't want to be
rapping when I'm
40 and [ __ ] Bro not not me right I'm
just great well how do you straighten
them like financially but I don't like
if I mean I saw how much you paid for
your chain yeah I think you're doing all
right uh no how old are you right now 25
yes I mean that's you got 15 years
before you hit 40. yeah that's what I'm
saying I mean look man now let's just
put out King's disease three and Nas is
Like 50. so
you know you could do this [ __ ] out
that's great yeah you could do I mean
you I mean look as long but
some people just really passionate
passionate to it like I got a passion
for it but half of that [ __ ] slick left
you know what I'm saying I miss a fake
ass industry man the rap game is super
weird I don't [ __ ] with them you know
what it is